The late Sir Sean Connery will no doubt be
remembered first and foremost for being the
man who originated the role of James Bond
on the big screen.
But prior to his retirement from acting in
2006, he starred in numerous iconic action
films.
Aside from the James Bond movies, Connery
also appeared in Indiana Jones and the Last
Crusade, Highlander, and The Rock - all of
which include explosive scenes.
That seems totally natural since they're all
action movies, but in a 2009 Total Film interview,
comic book writer Alan Moore alleged that
some of the scenes featuring explosions in
Connery projects were actually a result of
a bizarre clause in the actor's contract.
In his rant-filled interview, Moore discussed
The League of Extraordinary Gentlemen, which
was based on his comics of the same name.
The movie, directed by Stephen Norrington,
was Connery's final live-action project before
he retired from acting in 2006, and he went
on record saying that the filming process
left him disenchanted with modern Hollywood.
“I’m waiting to be impressed”
However, Moore blamed part of the movie's
troubles on the alleged demands of its star.
He claimed,
"The film cost £100 million because Sean
Connery wanted £17 million of that - and
a bigger explosion than the one he'd had in
his last film.
It's in his contract that he has to have a
bigger explosion with every film he's in.
In The Rock, he'd blown up an island, and
he was demanding for our film that he blow
up Venice or something like that.
It would have been the moon in his next movie."
“Well, you don't come any closer than that!”
It should be noted that Moore is famously
cantankerous about Hollywood (and the comic
book industry), and if Connery was on a quest
to have a huge explosion in every single one
of his movies, it's never been documented
publicly by anyone else.
That doesn't mean the clause never existed,
but there's a possibility that Moore was being
a tad hyperbolic.
What is true is that the famed 007 actor and
Norrington clashed on the set of The League
of Extraordinary Gentlemen.
Back when the movie was still in production
in 2002, an article in Entertainment Weekly
discussed the tensions on set, which included
Connery and Norrington allegedly nearly coming
to blows over an elephant gun.
Connery said at the time,
"Oh, yes, it's been difficult.
Very, very difficult.
There's no question about it."
In 2005, Connery opened up a bit more, telling
the BBC that his experience on the set of
The League of Extraordinary Gentlemen put
him off Hollywood for good.
He said,
"I'm fed up with the idiots ... the ever-widening
gap between people who know how to make movies
and the people who green-light the movies.
I don't say they're all idiots.
I'm just saying there's a lot of them that
are very good at it."
While he didn't explicitly call out Norrington
in that interview, in 2007, Connery did say
that the director "would have been arrested
for insanity," according to The Hollywood
Reporter.
The actor also admitted that he attempted
to wrest editorial control away from the young
director in hopes of salvaging the movie.
Connery's efforts didn't pan out, though,
and the movie ended up being a box office
flop anyway.
Ultimately, Moore's claim that Connery craved
big-budget explosions in his films is just
one more strange footnote in the history of
a movie with backstage drama so legendary
that it truly deserves a film of its own.